und weil ich dich so
richtig
20 jahre sportfreunde stiller auf dem
neuen album sturm und stille verbreiten
sie wieder gute laune
doch angesichts von krieg und terror
gibt es auch nachdenkliche töne
wir haben das super zeit wir waren total
zufrieden und happy da in unserer musik
machen und in unsere musik raus und auf
der anderen seite waren wir sehr traurig
darüber was dazu draußen in der welt
passiert und haben gespürt diese
gleichzeitigkeit extremer extrem
unterschiedliche gefühle
inzwischen sieben studioalben drei echos
sieben mal platin mit jubel hymnen und
schnörkellosen texten haben sich die
indie rocker in zwei jahrzehnten eine
riesige fangemeinde erspielt
alles was wir haben ist irgendwie auf
jubel gebaut
das ist alles so wahnsinnig positiv
entstanden durch das man musik macht
einfach und dass die menschen einen halt
mit freude irgendwie durch die welt
durch tragen
ich weiß
diese
2002 der erste top ten hit ein
liebeslied
doch ihre größte liebe geht dem fußball
die hobbykicker nehmen 2004 mit roque
santa cruz dem damaligen star des fc
bayern münchen einen song auf
ich logge trocken ist ja quasi ein
lebensgefühl würde ich sagen
sechs jahre zu stemmen
2006 rocken sie die
fußballweltmeisterschaft ihr song wir
zur inoffiziellen hymne der wm im
eigenen land und liefert den refrain für
die fußball begeisterung der deutschen
gemeinsam mit der nationalmannschaft
treten die sportis nach dem verpassten
finale am brandenburger tor in berlin
auf
ich glaube ich werde es nie vergessen
wie leuten von menschen völlig ausrasten
nur weil wir eins und zwei und drei und
vier und sagen
doch die bayern wollen sich nicht auf
das thema fußball beschränken
2009 kommen leisere töne mit einem album
für die reihe mtv unplugged
zwei nummer-eins-alben mehr als eine
million verkaufte platten
auch nach 20 jahren bleiben sich die
sportfreunde stiller treu
in der rückschau aufs eigene leben
sondern durchaus auch zu dem entschluss
kommen doch die geballte und der
erhobene faust bis zum ende oben zu
halten und leben genießen und das leben
als fest zu sehen
positiv in die vergangenheit und in die
zukunft blicken
typisch sportfreunde stiller
weil du mir
geschehen